willkommen zur forum manager der
interview reihe von phoenix das ist der
sender den sie gerade schauen und der
süddeutschen zeitung im
redaktionsgebäude der süddeutschen
zeitung sind wir heute und wir haben wie
immer studenten dabei studierende der
deutschen journalistenschule münchen ein
ganz besonderer jahrgang der fünfzigste
jahrgang dieser traditionsreichen
journalistenschule herzlich willkommen
und herzlich willkommen nina ruge
allseits bekannte fernsehmoderatorin und
partnerin in diesem schönen format
grüßen ihn an und er wirkt in diesen
heiligen hallen als chef der
wirtschaftsredaktion der süddeutschen
zeitung marc beise und das ist unser
gast er ist manager und unternehmer und
ich glaube ich darf sagen er ist der fc
bayern erst zum einen der vorsitzende
des aufsichtsrates dann ist er
vereins-präsident und davor war er 22
lange jahre sehr erfolgreicher manager
des fußballclubs aber es auch
geschäftsführender gesellschafter der
hofer kg in nürnberg also erstellt wurst
her
herzlich willkommen union ist
ja und wie es bei unserer tradition ist
haben wir jetzt die doppelte aufgabe war
sie ja zwei unternehmen führen zwei
unternehmen einer minute uns
vorzustellen
naja über bayern münchen viel zu
erzählen hieß er nach athen tragen ich
denke fast alle kennen den verein wir
sind würde ich sagen der erfolgreichste
fußballverein in deutschland was uns
besonders stolz macht auch
wahrscheinlich der wirtschaftlich
gesündeste ich denke wir haben im
letzten geschäftsjahr etwa 370 euro
umsatz gemacht und die zahlen genau wird
unser fast einen demnächst bekannt geben
einen ordentlichen gewinn wie seit über
20 jahren
was die firma 100 allen belangen geht
kann ich sagen dass wir dort mit etwa
200 angestellten im winter und 300 im
sommer wenn die grillzeit beginnt
original und bratwürste machen
zu 80 prozent machen wir original und
bei rostbratwürste zu 20 prozent
geflügel bratwurst derweil dass dem
zeitgeist mehr auch entspricht wir
machen einen umsatz von circa 50
millionen beliefern in ganz europa fast
jedem discounter verzierten supermarkt
aber auch die firma feinkost käfer und
wenn sie eine bratwurst bei aldi kaufen
die etwa viel billiger ist als bei käfer
dann ist es trotzdem die gleiche
qualität besonders stolz sind wir dass
wir seit einiger zeit auch in usa
verkaufen trader joe's dem kult
discounter und bei all dies wird bei
1200 läden und das war nicht einfach
und deswegen sind wir besonders stolz
auf beide sind sie stolz was ist denn
jetzt schwerer zu führen
ein fußballklub in zeiten astronomische
ablösesummen oder eine wurstfabrik in
zeiten in denen sich die
supermarktketten einen mörderischen
preiskampfs liefern
beides ist nicht einfach den fußball ist
natürlich immer ein schwieriges geschäft
weil es doch immer von den menschen
abhängt von der situation in der du
gerade bist und eine wurstfabrik ist
gerade in dieser zeit besonders
schwierig zu führen weil die
rohstoffpreise sehr sehr
stark im steigen sind das gilt nicht nur
für fleisch sondern auch für schaaf
seitlinger also der damm in dem wir die
wurst zu erfüllen
die haben sich in den letzten zwei
jahren um über 200 prozent erhöht und
hat uns allein bei 50 bis 60 euro mehr
kosten verursacht und das an den kunden
sprich die discounter weiterzugeben ist
nicht so einfach
ich spüre wie die ernährungsfachfrau
nina ruge jetzt ganz dringend über
dieses thema weiter reden wie wir machen
das auch aber ich glaube wir fangen mit
fußballern ärgernis und wir haben ja
gerade über mega deals geredet sie haben
gerade ein mega deal eingefädelt 40
millionen haben sie gezahlt für rafael
martinez musste das sein
das ist eine total berechtigte frage
weil ich mir vor paar jahren nie nie
hätte vorstellen können dass ein fc
bayern münchen
40 millionen euro ablösesumme für einen
spieler ausgibt aber jetzt war die
situation so unsere sportliche leitung
matthias sammer und jupp heynckes haben
uns mit dem vorstand und mich als
aufsichtsratsvorsitzender dann wenn es
ums geld geht gefragt werden muss
unheimlich bedrängt dass sie glauben mit
der besetzung des der nummer sechs als
im zentralen defensiven mittelfeld müsse
es dieser martinez sein und sie würden
in europa moment wenige spieler erkennen
wo alterklasse und so weiter alles passt
außer diesem javier martinez und da der
spieler in der in seinem vertrag eine
ablösesumme festgeschrieben hatte von 40
millionen die nicht verhandelbar war wir
haben viermal versucht mit dem
präsidenten ins gespräch zu kommen ich
war einmal auf einem kurzurlaub in
biarritz 150 kilometer weg davon und
karl heinz rummenigge hat den präsident
gefragt unser präsident ist in der nähe
ferien können sie denn jetzt auf eine
tasse kaffee empfang hat er gesagt kein
interesse 40 millionen oder nicht und
das war die situation und wir haben dann
lange lange lange zeit überlegt und
haben uns schlussendlich entschieden
weil wir es natürlich auch uns leisten
können wir haben die 40 millionen nicht
von der kreditabteilung unserer bank
geholt sondern von der festgehälter
teilung und deswegen finde ich das auch
mal akzeptabel aber es darf niemals zur
norm spieler
naja es gibt heute keinen spieler der
nicht mehrere positionen spielen könnte
wäre schlimm wenn ein spieler kommt und
sagt ich kann nur die sechs spielen alle
diese fünf spieler können die sechs die
acht die 10
zur not auch die innenverteidigung oder
rechter verteidiger spielen
frage könnten sie ja einen von denen
dann wieder verkaufen
das mit dem verkaufen gefällt mir nicht
weil wir beim fc bayern keinen spieler
verkaufen
wir könnten mit dem spieler darüber
reden ob er bereit wäre den verein zu
verlassen wenn er das will
und zu jedem geschäft in diesem buch
gehört drei personen drei parteien der
spieler der am ende entscheidet ob das
macht oder nicht
der abgebende verein oder aufnehmende
verein und die transferperiode ist am 31
august abgelaufen das heißt wir haben
jetzt im moment gar keine chance einen
spieler abzugeben
und das wird auch im winter schwierig
weil wenn ein spieler zu und sagt ich
bleibe über bayern münchen und das kommt
oft vor auch wenn er nicht spielt dann
bleibt er einen vertrag bei bayern ist
sakrosankt das ist ein bisschen spezial
situation bei ihnen sehr
wirtschaftsgespräche auch in der
wirtschaft das er sonst ja anders ich
kaufe eine firma also verkaufe ich
andere teile meines konzerns und so bei
anderen verein ist das auch so man kauft
jemanden dann hat man viel geld
ausgegeben dafür verkauft man ihm an
bayern geht das nicht bei eines
endstationen die meisten spieler die den
fc bayern verlassen haben haben ihn
ablösefrei verlassen
das heißt sie verdienen nicht mehr daran
ich betrachte die fußballspieler nicht
als wirtschaftsgut natürlich ist es rein
materiell ein wirtschaftsgut weil man
sie ab schreibt wie eine maschine
aber ich sage immer das ist ein mensch
und deswegen spreche ich nie von
verkaufen sondern ich muss einen
vernünftigen dialog führen mit meinen
angestellten und muss versuchen eine
lösung zu finden die beide seiten
zufriedenstellt
wird nie passieren dass wir einen
spieler wegschicken dass wir einen weg
mobben dass er vielleicht nicht mehr
spielt oder nicht mehr auf die bank darf
nur weil er seinen vertrag nicht
aufgelöst wird das gibt's bei bayern
nicht einen vertrag bei bayern heißt ein
vertrag für immer entweder er läuft aus
er entscheidet bleibt oder nicht nochmal
zu martinez vielleicht 40 millionen ist
nicht alles normalerweise kommen bei
solchen summen ja noch weitere beträge
dazu für was auch immer steuer betreuer
manager ich hab jetzt radikal umsteuern
ich habe gerade gelesen pamplona der
erste verein bei dem martinez gespielt
hat also gar nicht der von dem sehen
gekauft haben will nochmal 800.000 haben
als ausgleich dafür dass sie den spieler
ausgebildet haben also sind wir bei den
40 millionen wirklich am ende
oder rechnen sie mit 40 habe die
transfusion müsste die 800 aus müsste
nicht der fc bayern sondern die müsste
viel bezahlen das ist ein teil des es
gibt eine regelung bei der wafer die
besagt wenn du aus einem spieler den du
aus pamplona geholt hast den du weiter
ausgebildet hast wie du denn für viel
geld weiterverkaufen gibt es eine
bestimmte regelung welchen anteil die
der erste verein dann bekommt insofern
mit den 40 millionen haben wir den
unseren part bezahlt und wenn pamplona
möglicherweise ist es total berechtigt
ansprüche hat einen baum
sie können sich auch überlegen 40
millionen riesensumme die investieren
wir einfach ganz stringente die
nachwuchsförderung
wissen sie das ist mir dass ich es mir
zu kurz gesprungen
wenn wir die nachwuchsförderung 40
millionen investieren haben wir absolut
keine sicherheit dass wir in zwei jahren
eine bessere mannschaft haben und es
interessiert beim fc bayern in der ihnen
in der allianz arena wenn wir 70.000 am
wochenende haben überhaupt niemand wenn
er 60 oder 70 euro bezahlt hat dass wir
vielleicht in fünf jahren aus dem
gebildeter nachwuchsarbeit dann
vielleicht profit machen der zuschauer
will am samstag ins stadion
und er will am samstag unterhalten
werden dem user haben er will spaß hat
er wohl wieder voll kam und dabei ist es
ihm ziemlich wurscht wie wir das her
wie wir das machen ob wir das über die
jugendabteilung machen oder über das
lang angehäufte geld mal ausgeben
der zuschauer will am samstag schönen
fußballs 1 gegen mainz den interessiert
relativ wenig ob wir in fünf jahren aus
dem eigenen jugendbereich einen spieler
einsätze weil wir ja in diesem bereich
sowieso ziemlich führend in europa sind
in unserer mannschaft spielen die
meisten spieler die wir aus dem eigenen
jugendbereich ausgebildet haben das
andere nicht aus das eine schließt das
andere nicht aus ich muss doch noch 1
fragen weil mich diese 40 millionen
natürlich wie die meisten sehr
beeindruckt haben
es war ja auch ein ganz komplizierter
deal sie haben sehr kurz angesprochen
das geld hat ja nicht viel bau direkt
bekommen sondern es wurde ja sozusagen
über den verband übergeben bilbao war
gar nicht einbezogen in dieses spiel
ganz komplizierte juristische geschichte
erstens ws darauf gekommen wie stellt
man sowas fest dass man das so machen
kann und dann hätte ja auch was
schiefgehen können in dem deal wie man
sich das vorstellen sie saßen abends zu
hause und haben gebibbert hoffentlich
geht das gut heute
oder haben sie mal sogar ein vertrauen
natürlich erstens haben wir ja sagen wir
sehr gute steuerberater finanzberater
aber auch einen eigenen anwalt und diese
anwalt ist mit dem scheck mit einer
privatmaschine nach madrid geflogen hat
den scheck persönlich beim spanischen
fußballverband abgegeben hat dafür
gesorgt dass der an die richtige stelle
kam und mit demselben chatter den
spieler mit nach münchen genommen zu
ärztlichen untersuchung also das haben
wir schon dafür gesorgt dass der nicht
in falsche hände kommen klingt sowieso
ein agentenaustausch bist ja das ist
nicht richtig weil diese regelung über
die wir jetzt reden die es in spanien
gang und gäbe die verträge in den
spanischen nach dem spanischen gesetz
beinhalten bei jedem spieler eine
ablöseklausel das heißt wenn du einen
fünfjahresvertrag dort unterschreibt
wird automatisch irgendeine ablösesumme
festgelegt zu der der spieler zu jeder
tages und nachtzeit den verein verlassen
kann und von dieser klausel hat der
spieler gebrauch gemacht
den scheck mich haben zuerst wenn da
muss man muss natürlich wissen es ist
natürlich aus meiner sicht total
unverantwortlich vom präsidenten
so zu handeln denn der verein ist ja
nicht so auf rosen gebettet aber der
präsident hat wahlen im herbst und
präsident ist ein sehr stolzer mann und
er hat gesagt wenn ich eine chance haben
will präsident zu bleiben dann muss ich
hier stur bleiben obwohl er mit
sicherheit sehr sehr oft gedacht hat am
liebsten würde ich die 40 millionen
nehmen und den spieler irgendwie doch
behalten aber das geht nun mal nicht
zufrieden zufrieden bzw
sein kollege deiner sportredaktion hat
diese wunderbare headline eines eines
leitartikels gefunden schulden schießen
tore nach dem motto die meisten vereine
in europa sind wahnsinnig verschuldet
gerade die die wahnsinnig erfolgreich
sind ist eigentlich ziemlich ungerecht
darüber würde ich wahnsinnig gerne reden
und ich denke mal du auch die armee
hatte jetzt for financial fairplay
einzuführen das heißt also ich habe ein
paar zahlen aufgeschrieben der fc
barcelona 400 millionen schulden real
madrid das ist ja alles nicht offen
gelegt aber auch in dem dreh die
englische premier league soll 4
milliarden schulden insgesamt haben
kaufen ohne ende spieler und sind dann
auch noch siegreich klar
wie finden sie das und finden sie auch
richtig was die uefa da im detail vor
hat wenn die wafer konsequent das
umsetzt was sie sich vorgenommen hat
dann ist es okay dann darf es ab dem
ersten juli 2012 also in diesem jahr
kein verein mehr in einem geschäftsjahr
mehr als 15 millionen verluste machen
kumuliert auf drei jahre 45 und wenn er
das nicht einhält dann gibt es strafen
in der ersten phase wird das vielleicht
hohe geldstrafe zeit in der zweiten
phase vielleicht sagen wir mal das eine
oder andere spiel in der champions
league nicht zu hause oder so und die
härteste strafe wäre natürlich
ausschluss aus der champions league nach
heutigem stand mussten einige vereine in
europa schon sanktioniert werden ich bin
mal gespannt wie herr platine der uns
das immer bestätigt wie konsequent er
das umsetzt allerdings müssen sie
natürlich in europa 22 arten von
vereinen unterscheiden des eines sind
die vereine die richtig schulden haben
direkt bei den banken dazu zählt
offensichtlich auch barcelona real
madrid aber auch viele vereine in
italien und in spanien auch in england
aber es gibt natürlich auch eine neue
kategorie von von feiern die von reichen
araber teilweise amerikanern besetzen
weil ich sage dann zwei beispiele russen
fc chelsea hat bei seinem eigner der
mann abramowitsch 12 milliarden schulden
ja wenn der irgendwann sagt ich mache
jetzt nicht mehr infos person im fell
dann kann sie chelsea als das lamm kiosk
kaufen
dasselbe gilt für manchester city
der emir von abu dhabi hat in den
letzten jahren ich schätze mal 56 700
millionen euro reingesteckt der verein
hat keine schulden
denn der verein gehört den emir von abu
dhabi würde auch das wird jetzt
interessant weil verlustausgleich das
ist ja nicht mehr gestattet ja und das
wird interessant oder in paris haben
leute aus katar aus dem königshaus den
verein übernommen haben in diesem merkel
auf 2 150 oder 200 millionen euro
investiert das können die auch nicht aus
der eigenen tasche gebracht haben also
das wird interessant wie das gemacht
wird und ich bin mal sehr gespannt ob
das umgesetzt wird wenn das umgesetzt
wird einige vereine wie inter mailand ac
mailand versuchen der financial verbleib
wirklich umzusetzen mit der konsequenz
dass sie natürlich keinen großen
sportlichen vorsprung mehr haben
das wird wiederum würde bedeuten dass
die bundesliga die am bix und
verschuldet ist in ganz europa ich
glaube mit nur mit fünf oder sechs 100
millionen insgesamt
dass die bundesliga die meiner meinung
nach das financial fair play in weiten
teilen jetzt schon erfüllt dass die
eigentliche nächsten zehn jahren sehr
prosperieren müsste und mittlerweise
gold derzeit und auf den deutschen
fußball zu klemmen das würde ich auch
auf der für die bundesliga gelten das
müssten sie wohl in effelder eben
übertragen weil es in deutschland ein
lizenzierungsverfahren seit vielen
jahren gibt wo die vereine gezwungen
sind vernünftig zu wirtschaften uns
kriegen sie keine lizenz ist es
eigentlich so schlimmer eine kurze
anschlussfrage ist das eigentlich so
schlimm wenn ein einzelner mehr zehn wir
haben das ja auch in deutschland mit
hoffenheim zum beispiel wirklich sagt
ich bin so fußballbegeistert dass ich da
wahnsinnig viel geld in so ein verein
stärke haben sie da nicht auch
verständnis höher für diese begeisterung
wenn das wirkliche begeisterung ist und
ein geld ist dass der mit zehn nicht
mehr zurück haben will dann habe ich
dafür verständnis im fall dietmar hopp
der seiner region seinem heimatverein
das geld zur verfügung stellt und meiner
meinung nach überhaupt nicht vorhat das
zurückzuverlangen findet das total in
ordnung aber wenn er es leute wie diese
grenze bei manchester united geht die
die dann 6 700 millionen euro
investieren um manchester united zu
kaufen als erste maßnahme dann den old
trafford das stadion verkaufen
riesige schulden aufhäufen in der
hoffnung dass man in fünf oder sechs
jahren das zeug dann für 1 2 milliarden
verkaufen kann dann habe ich dafür kein
verständnis wenn mir gerade gesagt den
bundesliga clubs geht der
vergleichsweise gut in sachen
schuldenstand gab es jetzt gerade eine
aktuelle umfrage 94 prozent der
bundesliga manager beurteilen die
wirtschaftliche lage ihrer branche als
gut bis sehr gut aber sie hatten 2008
2009 während der krise richtig probleme
wir steuern jetzt wieder ein ziemlich
raue gewässer wird es auch wieder eng
für die bundesligavereine natürlich
nicht vom fc bayern nein ich glaube dass
bei uns in deutschland sehr viel
passiert ist in den letzten sechs jahren
speziell seit der weltmeisterschaft 2006
die infrastrukturen in den städten sind
fantastisch die stadien sie die besten
der welt
die ganzen vereine haben seit vielen
jahren auch jugend internaten aufgebaut
sie haben nachwuchszentren aufgebaut das
heißt sie können auch jugendliche junge
spieler aus den eigenen reihen
entwickeln also insofern mache ich mir
in diesem bereich um die bundesliga im
moment am wenigsten sorgen vor allen
dingen weil fußball in deutschland
zurzeit so gesellschaftsfähig ist wie
noch nie wir haben den höchsten
zuschauerschnitt in ganz europa mit über
42.000 im schnitt müssen wir vergessen
nicht verletzt auch stadien mit 20 und
25.000 als im schnitt 42.000 das waren
früher zahlen aus mit dem haus in
italien spanien england gewohnt war aber
da haben wir die bund die ganze welt
jetzt schon überholt
jetzt kommst du mit deiner kostenfrage
ist unbedingt genau danach redet über
die managementqualität eine sportsendung
es ist ja eine wirtschaftssendung
gebremst wird ja aber jetzt kommt noch
nicht einmal eine frage muss die stellen
ich weiß dass das thema für sie
vielleicht nicht so beliebt ist und sie
werden auch schon mal was dazu gesagt
haben 19 sie wissen was ich meine sie
haben darauf zu gelebt dieses champions
league finale hier in münchen und dann
läuft das spiel gar nicht so schlecht an
das läuft und dann kommt eben die
verlängerung und dann kommt das
elfmeterschießen und dann geht schon
fast egal von wem dieser ball an den
pfosten
ist da für sie eine welt
zusammengebrochen an dem tag schon muss
ich sagen ich bin ja sehr emotional
dabei und aber ich kann auch dazwischen
zeit ganz gut abschalten aber wenn du in
einem spiel das so wichtig ist und dass
so was ist was wahrscheinlich in den
nächsten 30 40 jahren nie mehr möglich
ist dass du im endspiel bist in deiner
eigenen stadt in deinem eigenen stadion
wenn du dann gegen einen gegner wie zwei
jahre vorher gegen in der man einfach
schlechter bis da die waren besser und
dann verlierst du dann sagst du okay
aber wenn du da oben sitzt 120 minuten
du spielst auf ein tor früher haben wir
immer im hinterhof auf ein tor gespielt
so war das spiel gegen chelsea 20 zu
zwei ecken
das ist normal ein torverhältnis wenn du
gegen oder harring schließt ja und dann
gewinnst dann hast du elfmeter in der
verlängerung
du hast riesige torchancen während das
spielzeit dann führst du 10
dann ist 88 minute 1 1 dann hast du in
der verlängerung wie gesagt
den elfmeter dann hat bully zwei minuten
vor schluss 110 prozent und dann
verlierst du dann spricht natürlich was
zusammen klar sitze da drüber weg ja wir
waren wie gelähmt muss ich sagen ich
hatte danach eine sitzung vorstand
trainer und ich wir hatten war gut dass
urlaub war
wir waren leer wir waren ausgebrannt wir
waren
wir hatten ja anschließend eine eine
party vorbereitet aber 1200 leute
eingeladen 400 kamen und nach zwei
stunden war alles weg was war es war
einfach es ging ja auch vielen fans noch
einmal wir hatten ihre familie immer
ganz konsequent aus der presse raus aber
da hat man hat gesehen dass am ende ihre
frau susie sie auch umarmt hat aber da
ist natürlich in so einer situation aber
ist so sie hin und wieder kann die ihnen
beim stressabbau helfen beim straßenbau
hilft die mir am besten indem ich zu
hause eine oase habe in dem ich einfach
nicht mit dem fußball konfrontiert werde
wenn wir nicht sprechen will über
fußball kann ich das aber da wird da
nicht noch kann jeder posten für soll
jeder jedes foul durch diskutiert
sondern da komme ich nach aus einen
tegernsee und kann wirklich abschalten
und das ist natürlich traumhaft in all
das was ich geschafft habe hätte ich
ohne sie nie geschafft weil wenn sie
nicht die ganze familie die nicht die
den ausgleich geschaffen hätte
geschaffen hätten dann wäre es schwierig
gewesen haben sie mal kurz überlegt nach
der nach diesem pfostenschuss in den
tagen danach aufzuhören
das tue ich nie ich würde immer nur oben
wie unten und gewinnen sie dieses die
meisterschaft glaube ich ist sicher in
dieser saison
tschuldigung und champions league sind
die chancen auch nicht schlecht oder
ich glaube schon dass wir noch eine
etwas bessere mannschaft haben im
letzten jahr weil wir auch bei diesem
endspiel festgestellt haben dass wir in
der breite nicht gut aufgestellt worden
wenn man dann darunter geführt hast auf
die bank und hat festgestellt was hast
du eigentlich noch zu zu setzen so zehn
minuten vor schluss wenn ich so jetzt
denke jetzt will ich jetzt noch mal das
spiel da hätte und ich hätte dann noch
gomez spielt mittelstürmer und dann
hätten wir noch pizza auf der bank und
wir hätten manches kritisch auf der bank
da hätte ich mir schon gedacht dass wir
da noch eine taktische variante
dabei hätten die wir da nicht hatten und
deshalb glaube ich haben wir jetzt nicht
spektakulär gekauft martin es schon aber
so ansonsten haben wir glaube ich der
vorstand ich bin ja da nicht jetzt
direkt im tagesgeschäft aber unser
vorstand hat fantastisch gearbeitet
indem er die breite des kraters
unglaublich ausgeweitet hat und ich
denke dass wir dieses jahr 18 bis 20
fast gleichwertige spieler haben so dass
auch durch verletzungen durch
formschwankungen durch müdigkeit
doch viel zu egalisieren ist und deshalb
glaube ich dass wir dieses jahr gute
chancen haben
ähnlich weit zu kommen und natürlich
braucht man titel das ist keine frage
drei jahre ohne till bayern das geht
nicht mehr jetzt bin ich ganz ruhig
anhalt zu sagen gar nichts mehr bitte ja
jetzt kommen wir zu ihrem management
leistungen
sie waren ja mal auf den titel vom
manager magazin und überschrift lautete
was die wirtschaft vom fc bayern lernen
kann
können sie das in zwei sätzen oder im
freien vielleicht zusammen ich mag nie
über mich oder über uns sprechen weil
das sollen andere beurteilen in dem
artikel standen einige dinge die
chefredaktoren einige suppe bald so eine
andere meinten schreiben zu müssen
sollen sie ich denke wir haben immer
versucht vernünftig zu wirtschaften
wieder unterbrechen
als sie angefangen haben da waren sie 27
jahre alt ich glaube es war 79 da hatte
der verein sechs millionen umsatz und
dreieinhalb millionen schulden in euro
gerechnet in europa und ganz genau so
und was haben sie gemacht um den
turnaround so schnell hin zu kriegen sie
haben ein ziemlich schnell hingekriegt
damals war dass ein fußballverein und
von den zwölf millionen mark umsatz
waren 85 prozent zuschauereinnahmen das
heißt wenn es geregnet hat kann man
weniger zuschauer darf nicht vergessen
die berten damals eine sehr erfolgreiche
mannschaft in den 70er jahren mit
beckenboden mit meyer mit müller dreimal
den europapokal gewonnen und trotzdem
nur ein zuschauer durchschnitt von
32.000 ich habe von anfang an versucht
den verein wirtschaftlich auf eine
andere basis zu stellen das heißt wir
waren diese einnahmen aus den anderen
bereichen das heißt marketing
merchandising und fernsehen viel zu tief
ich wollte einfach nicht dass wir
abhängig sind ob es regnet oder schneit
sondern ich wollte die zuschauer haben
ich will sie auch heute haben als
ambiente als tolle atmosphäre
aber wir schöpfen die zuschauer die ins
stadion kommen nicht bis heute kostet
ein klares dauerkartenplatz 7 euro 50 im
stehplatz 7 euro 50
damit kann ich ribery nicht bezahlen das
heißt es war von anfang an darauf
ausgerichtet den fc bayern
wirtschaftlich auf eine andere basis zu
stellen und es hat drei schwerpunkte
jetzt zuschauereinnahmen sind nicht zu
verwässern das stadion ist immer
ausverkauft
die kapazität ist jetzt 71.000 wir sind
die gesamten gesamte saison ausverkauft
wir haben das pokalspiel gegen
kaiserslautern im oktober ausverkauft
wir haben die drei europapokal spiele
gegen relativ unattraktive gegner
ausverkauf also da brauchen wir nichts
machen dann war das thema marketing wir
hatten damals
naja magirus deutz darauf gehabt wir
haben 600 tausend mark bezahlt ja in der
zwischenzeit nehmen wir in diesem ganzen
bereich nicht nur von einem aber von
vielleicht zehn zwölf firmen 85
millionen euro ein
die deutsche telekom zahlt ca 6 728
millionen je nachdem wie weit wir kommen
dann haben wir viele große sponsoren wie
audi als automobil ausrüster adidas als
ausrüster für den sport und viele viele
andere und es liegen wir in europa auf
nummer 185 millionen
dann haben wir einen bereich
merchandising
damals gab es bei bayern münchen eine
kleine poststelle da gab es zwei wimpel
und zwar ist und eine postkarte und das
haben wir gemacht haben sagte kann nicht
sein bin ich nach amerika geflogen
amerika san francisco vor die niners
american football club san francisco
giants baseball club da war ich mit
meiner frau eine woche hat man das alles
angeschaut wenn ich morgens in einen
laden gegangen doch auch das war der
fanartikel laden von den san francisco
giants waren morgens um 11 uhr war der
laden brechend voll aber nicht mit
leuten mit einer fan kutte und einem
schal sondern anzüge geschäftsleute aus
den banken haben für ihre kids
fanartikel habe ich zu meiner frau
gesagt wenn wir das mal geschafft haben
das rotlicht montagmorgen leute hier der
laden stimmen dann ziehe ich
zurückgekommen herangefahren erster
laden an der säbener straße
da machen wir jetzt etwa auf 30 jetzt
war mal 240 quadratmeter 50,3 millionen
umsatz gemacht die dazwischen seit
machen wir fünf sechs millionen haben
wir einen kleinen megastore dann haben
wir orlando straße direkt im hofbräuhaus
25 quadratmeter mach mal drei millionen
umsatz dann hauptbahnhof wenn sie die
treppe runter kommen rechts 100
quadratmeter umsatz dann haben wir jetzt
den mega store in der allianz arena auf
800 quadratmeter machen wir an einem
spieltag bis zu 200.000 euro an einem
tag das heißt deshalb werden wir nie
70.000 dauerkarten verkaufen weil bin
immer dieselben leute im stande sind
kaufen sie keine fanartikel mehr
besonders stolz bin ich auf einen laden
in oberhausen oberhausen zwischen
schalke und dortmund um genau deshalb
dass das sich die schalker die
dortmunder jeden baum wird die an
unserem landen im centro in oberhausen
verweisen
das freut mich ja und da mal haben am
anfang ziemlich verlust gemacht und dann
haben unsere leute
die leute gesagt sind sie verrückt das
sind der erste laden wo wir rote zahlen
war halt warten außerdem das ist es muss
es uns wert sein
zwischenzeit machen wir auch dort zwei
millionen zweieinhalb nur in umsatz und
einen kleinen gewinn
aber es wird noch keine antworten der
laden muss sein was mich interessieren
würde wie haben sie das damals meine
heute sind sie da in einer marktführer
situation wenn andere das nachmachen
wollen ist es sehr schwer weil sie im
grunde den markt abgrasen
aber als sie angefangen haben wenn man
verfolge schildert wirtschaftlich super
erfolgreich also fußballerisch super
erfolgreich wirtschaftlich nicht andere
hätten das auch machen können es gab ja
große vereine gladbach hsv
wer auch immer damals die hätten ja auch
in diese fußstapfen oder hätten auch so
anfangen können irgendwie haben es nur
sie gemacht
ja ich nehme an dass es vier fünf städte
in deutschland gebe wo man mehr draus
machen kann ich denke zuerst an hamburg
wer dann vielleicht berlin aber deswegen
ärgere ich mich immer wenn es immer von
den reichen bayern gesprochen wird dann
sage ich wir haben nicht im lotto
gewonnen wir haben keine reiche tante
aus amerika sondern wir haben versucht
aus den möglichkeiten die ein
fußballverein hat das bestmögliche zu
machen und ich glaube darauf sind wir
besonders stolz und werden immer gesagt
der hoeneß nein das denn hier waren
der fc bayern ist deshalb stark weil wir
eine führungsstruktur haben die seit 20
25 jahren relativ wenig fluktuation hat
das war beckenbauer als präsident
rummenigge der in den vorstand kam karl
hopfner dales leider eine des jahres
aufhört der fast 30 jahre gearbeitet hat
hat man oft und ich bleibe immer daraus
amerika die sachen wieder hingeschmissen
bin zu einer der viel aufreißt aber die
kleinarbeit die bin ich jetzt kein
großer freund aber der hat dann die der
hat dann die die dinge so ziert die
verträge gemacht aus paris kommen denn
denn den ribéry vertrag aushandeln 25
millionen aber dann die die die zwischen
geräusche aus handel mit dem franzosen
da das war nicht so einfach und das hat
karl hopfner gemacht insofern ist die
große stärke des fc bayern dass wir
immer ein tolles team waren und da mayer
vorfelder der präsident von stuttgart
hat mal gesagt hat in münchen da schießt
und einer kanone immer irgendeiner
weißt du nicht welche und das war der
vorteil dass wir auf einer breiteren
basis gearbeitet haben und jeder jeden
absetzen konnte und dass wir hier und so
prima verstanden haben und das war das
eigentliche erfolgsgeheimnis gucken doch
jetzt vielleicht schon mal ganz kurz in
die zukunft wenn der hopfner
finanzvorstand was das ist ja eigentlich
unersetzbarer typ was brauchen sie dafür
ein gucken sie da er personalpolitisch
nach einem controller oder gucken sie
mal fußballer
naja natürlich ein fußballer mit dem
fussball wir brauchen einen
finanzexperten der der den fußball liebt
also ich könnte mir jetzt nicht
vorstellen dass einer von morgan stanley
kommt und sagt montag die hand jetzt
ihren wochenende gespielt
das kommt überhaupt nicht in frage und
es muss einer sein aber es muss keiner
sein der dem hansa immer noch sagt am
montag bei der marke montag besprechung
warum hat er jetzt mit nicht neben
ausgespannt den ball in den winkel genau
das ist nicht unbedingt not sind da
jetzt noch nicht
vielleicht nur noch ganz kurze was ich
ganz interessant fand ist auch neue
vermarktungsstrategien sie können müssen
ja immer weiter im grunde auch vorweg
gehen
da gibt es bei fcb oder fcb also ein
online portal für fans mit dem man
natürlich auch wieder geld verdienen
kann
abgesehen davon dass sie wahrscheinlich
da nicht drauf gehen werden weil sie
diese modernen medien ja gar nicht
nutzen
was versprechen sich davon ja ich meine
wenn der präsident nicht unbedingt nein
ich habe kein iphone
wenn er das nicht benutzt und dann heißt
es noch lange nicht dass nicht der fc
bayern das nicht hat also das ist ja die
große stärke dass wir für alles
fachleute haben wir haben eigens ein
eigenes expertenteam das für neue medien
als dass zuständiges und wir haben eine
internetseite die mehr als 50 millionen
mal im monat angeklickt wird damit sind
wir mit weitem abstand die nummer eins
im fußball und
wir haben jetzt auch facebook seite wir
haben alles mögliche kein großer freund
davon aber wenn mich leute unsere leute
da überzeugen dass das unbedingt sein
muss dann wird das gemacht dass sie kein
iphone haben ist er vielleicht noch
nicht so verwerflich sie könnten ja ein
vergleichsmodell einer anderen firma
haben aber ich glaube sie haben noch
nicht mal die fertigkeit ein smartphone
richtig zu benutzen außer telefonieren
machen sie glaube ich mit den kleinen
dingern gar nicht so sicher mein handy
und dem telefonieren
es reicht ja also ich habe eine keine
sms kein twittern keine e mails
schreiben sms kommen werden wir schon
man kann hier schon eine schicken aber
immer wenn 100 drauf sind glücklich sie
ungelesen ungelesen ok und e mails
nutzen sie auch nicht meine sekretärin
hat eine e-mail-adresse meine frau hat
eine e-mail-adresse ich habe keine
position moderner mensch viel mehr ruhe
deswegen ich glaube in der zeit wo
andere ihr ich hab mal ausgerechnet ich
muss ich würde am tag etwa 500 e-mails
kriegen wenn ich die alle leser sind
zwei stunden weg dann muss ich etwa 80
prozent die trotz und aussortieren und
um die 20 prozent dann zu beantworten
sind wieder zwei stunden weg also konnte
ich fast nichts mehr arbeiten so kommen
die e mails zu meinem sekretariat oder
zu meiner frau und die sortieren sie aus
dann kann ich mich darauf konzentrieren
und unter die e mail adresse meiner frau
benutzt natürlich nur freunde und und
leitet die uns wirklich nahe stehen und
im büro habe ich zwei sekretärinnen die
sich darum kümmern und ich habe das sehr
oft festgestellt wenn ich jetzt ins
flugzeug steigen nach nach berlin
fliegen dann mäßigen spiegel oder was
auch immer und dann schlafe ich auch mal
eine halbe stunde und dann sehe ich
leute
wir haben noch ein headset dran und dann
bis sie kommen ein stürmen ins flugzeug
und dann tippen sie dreiviertel stunde
und dann kaum ist der flieger gelandet
dann geht's wieder weiter und burnout
ist nicht mehr weit sind wir schon
mitten im führungsstil den wir
diskutieren wollen ich finde in ihrer
branche
haben ihr manager eine ganz besondere
herausforderung zu bestehen auf der
einen seite natürlich die machtfülle ist
immer klar
aber dann kommt dieser glamour dazu das
irrsinnige interesse der medien und
natürlich auch auf allen ebenen
vielleicht auch die bestechlichkeit dass
sie das heißt bestechlichkeit auf jeden
fall die verführung durch werbeverträge
oder sonstiges noch nebenbei eine ganze
menge geld verdienen zu können und damit
vielleicht nicht mehr mit 100 prozent
für das unternehmen da zu sein sondern
erstmal auch für sich selbst
wie kriegen sie das hin dass der verein
sie selber gehen mit gutem beispiel
voran aber wie kriegen sie das hin dass
der ganze verein möglichst nicht
verfügbar ist also clever können sie ja
bei mir ziemlich ausschließen weil sie
haben eine lange zeit leute gemacht aber
ich bin da nie vorgekommen
da bin ich ganz stolz darauf heute
meinte nein ich kann aber viel zu früh
aber ich denke das wichtigste ist dass
man dass man versucht so zu sein wie man
ist ich muss sagen ich habe da überhaupt
kein konzept das ich jetzt sage ich muss
jetzt da so machen ich gehe ich aufs
oktoberfest gehen oder würde ich
irgendwo in einer kneipe bin dann kommen
leute dann da gebe ich ein autogramm da
lasse ich mich fotografieren und wenn
mir das zu viel ist wenn ich jetzt aufs
oktoberfest gehen und ich glaube vom
löwen prozess um hippodrom über 300 mal
fotografiert dann sage in zukunft geld
halt mal einmal weniger aufs oktoberfest
dass das ist leider so und ich muss
ehrlich sagen mich stört das nicht ich
bin eine person der öffentlichkeit wenn
ich mich da rein begeben muss ich damit
rechnen dann kann ich nicht schlecht
gelaunt sein habe ich viel von franz
beckenbauer gelangt denn noch nie so bin
ich mit ihnen irgendwo war kein
autogramm gegeben hat nicht groß kurz
gesagt komm morgen gesagt hat wir sind
mal also bei uns kurzfristig trainer war
sehen wir mal in tegernsee wo wir im
trainingslager waren samstagmorgen immer
spazieren gegangen und da bin ich mit
ihm zugelaufen und die spaziergänger die
hat ja mal gerissen wenn der beckenbauer
in einer guten morgen gesagt hat es gibt
da überhaupt wird das der ihnen jetzt
gut morgens und ich glaube das ist ganz
wichtig dass man authentisch ist dass
man nicht irgendeine rolle spielt dass
man
nicht ich mache überhaupt keinen planen
wenn ich sage jetzt meine frau oft ja
ich gehe mal treffen und ins büro und
dann war es eben sieben oder acht das
ist so aber ich war auch letzte woche
von mittwoch bis gestern abend um sieben
in mallorca golf spielen und ich habe
fünf tage lang jeden tag rolf schmidt es
war wunderbar
glauben sie dass man es leider nicht
erfolgt glauben sie dass man so auch ein
unternehmen das nicht im entertainment
bereich angesiedelt wäre führen kann mit
diesem es ist im grunde ein bauchgefühl
nachdem sie leben viele dinge ist sicher
würden sie das empfehlen für alle oder
sagen sie das klappt nur beim fc bayern
ich glaube es gibt kein handbuch genau
das ist richtiger weise was ich sagen
das muss jeder für sich entscheiden ich
sage ihnen den den finanzvorstand den
wir jetzt gesucht haben wenn wir jetzt
in der süddeutschen in der faz oder im
internet ausgeschrieben hätten
da hätten wir doch was weiß ich bei karl
hopfner vor 30 jahren haben wir 400
bewerbungen herz wer hat jetzt 5000
bekommen das ist doch ganz schwierig und
dann und dann musst du dich darauf
richtig hand hast nein ich habe mir seit
viel zeit 34 jahre ich wusste dass karl
irgendwann aufhört habe ich mir die welt
angeschaut
sie wissen schon
wir werden das in der nächsten 6 8
wochen bekanntgeben
und wir haben keine keinen hack an der
eingeschaltet wir haben nichts wir haben
vier fünf leute ich habe eine super
aufsichtsrat ich habe den herrn heiner
von adidas den herrn stadler von audi in
ein winterkorn von vw der rampe von der
unicredit edmund stoiber mit dem bereich
grad mittagessen dann haben wir den
markwort von focus wir haben den
finanzchef der telekom also aus diesem
kreis gibt es dann vorschläge und dann
redet man mit dem einen oder andern und
dann und dann fokussiert sich das auf
ein oder zwei und dann sagen jetzt
glaube ich haben und das ist ganz
wichtig weil wenn man in dem geschäft
versucht nach einem handbuch zu arbeiten
dann ist es ganz schwierig sagen
beispiel managerspiel im computer ist ja
heute ganz modern
ja und wenn man nach managerspiel spielt
dann beginnt man eigentlich fast jedes
spiel weil wenn einem der luca toni
nicht passt dann tauscht sich aus
aber wie im wirklichen leben ist wenn du
luca toni in der halbzeit auswechselte
nach hause er hat die schnauze voll und
die süddeutsche und die bild und tz die
scheiben von montag bis mittwoch dicht
über das spiel sondern warum luca toni
nach hause gewesen ist und hast du ärger
ohne ende
wo den griff zu kriegen der ist viel
schwieriger wie darüber nachzudenken
würde tore schießen und dafür gibt's
kein handbuch also musst du das ist ein
paar mahnende spieler kräfte du hast es
mit das vergessen all diese journalisten
die über uns schreibt wir haben es ein
verdammt noch mal mit menschen zu tun
und die kann ich nicht wie eine maschine
obwohl ich sie schreibe ein und
ausschalten und dann funktioniert das
sie haben einen ein manager gehabt als
nachfolger nerlinger auf den große
hoffnung gesetzt worden sind von ihnen
vermutlich auch den haben sie mehr oder
weniger über nacht ausgewechselt weil er
ihre erwartung offensichtlich nicht
erfüllt haben den hals müssen auch mal
brutal sein den haben dass das war eine
ganz brutale entscheidung aber den habe
ich eben nicht über nacht ausgewechselt
er hat heute morgen habe ich seine
sekretärin die weiterhin bei uns
arbeitet hat mir ausgerechnet christian
ist jetzt wieder in der lage mit mir zu
reden er würde gerne mit mir essen gehen
also so ist es nicht ich habe christian
nerlinger eine chance gegeben einen
jungen mann auf dem ich viel hoffnung
gesetzt habe aber ich hatte einfach das
gefühl am ende dass er das nicht schafft
und ich habe ihm vier wochen bevor wir
uns getrennt haben gesagt und er auch in
einem vier augen gespräch haben wir uns
darauf verständigt dass wir auseinander
gehen und dass er uns die möglichkeit
gibt in ruhe die sache mit sammer zu
finalisieren und als wir das hacken dann
haben wir uns getrennt also das ist
nicht so und außerdem war der bezahlt
bis sein vertrag zu ende geht der der
sie heute sind
auch als führungsperson sind sie der
auch geworden weil sie zwei
jetzt sage ich mal abstürze hatten ein
richtiger und eine ein gesundheitlicher
der eine absturz war mit einer
sportmaschine sind zu einem länderspiel
geflogen und alle die freunde die dabei
waren sind gestorben um gekommen sie
waren der einzige der überlebte vor 30
jahren und vor 20 jahren haben sie
schwere darmoperation gab die ebenfalls
lebensbedrohlich war hat sie das auch
genau an dieser menschlichkeit mit der
sie letztlich den ganzen laden führen
auch wenn sie zum teil der fis hat sie
das geprägt glaube ich nicht
man nimmt sich ja vor als ich dann aus
dem flugzeug aus dem chrome also aus dem
trauma erwartet und dann eine woche
später wieder in münchen gelandet bin
wurde ich dann noch mal eine woche in
großhadern auf herz und nieren überprüft
und dann bin ich anschließend zwei
wochen in urlaub gefahren
dann nimmt man sich vor du machst diese
sieht nicht mehr du machst sehen das
nicht mehr
und dann musst du dich irgendwann
entscheiden hätte ich nicht mehr fliegen
sondern hätte ich keinen stress mehr
haben sollen hätten samstag 16 tage der
wohl also geht nicht ich glaube eher was
mich geprägt hat ist erstens das
elternhaus bei uns ich komme aus ganz
kleinen verhältnissen hat eine kleine
metzgerei thema wurscht wo der vater
morgens um 3 uhr aufgestanden ist und
gemacht hat bis mittags um 5 die mutter
um 7 uhr den laden aufgeschlossen hat
und am wochenende die buchhaltung
gemacht hat dazwischen die verkäuferin
war das war mal das eine und das andere
war ich muss ja wegen einer
knieverletzung hab kein meniskus im
rechten knie mit 27 jahren aufhören und
ich hatte immer schon so mit 324 als die
verletzung kam gewusst dass ich nicht
mehr lange spielen kann
damals waren die herzen nicht soweit gab
es keine autos kopie da konnte wurde
mein bei einer meniskus-operation hast
du noch so ein schnitt klappt heute hast
du vielleicht so einen
also ich war ziemlich vorbereitet dass
es nicht mehr lange geht und eines tages
kann unser masseur josef fritsch ein
kleiner einige jahre zu mir der masia
max juli musste passen auf warum wollen
sie dich verkaufen warum habe ich heute
morgen manager massiv massiert und hat
er mit präsident gesprochen präsident
hat gesagt sobald er wieder gesund ist
muss er verkaufen
und da habe ich mir gesagt wenn ich das
mal machen
das werde ich eben nicht machen nicht
nach oben buckeln nach unten treten
sondern genau umgekehrt ich bin der
größte freund des schwachen des kranken
und der größte feind oder der größte
kritiker des starken in franck ribery
sechs tore schießt brauche ich nicht der
1006 akteur sein
das sind die anderen da aber dass ich
beim länderspiel das kreuzband reißt
dann sitze ich am nächsten morgen bei
seinem langsam krank wird und das hat
mich stark geprägt jetzt mal die kurve
noch so wusste ja jetzt gibt es viele
fragen wie hals anschluss so schön
passen würden aber die wurst muss sein
vielleicht erst mal die wichtigste frage
werden gerade eben ihre eltern die ihr
vater bei metzgermeister die haben sich
ja kaum gelegt damit sie abitur machen
konnten sie und ihr bruder und sie haben
dann als sie schon manager waren und das
war ein richtig toller job da waren sie
noch ganz jungen job ich glaube vier
jahre beim fc bayern dann haben sie sich
das auch noch ans bein gehängt und in
nürnberg diese fabrik aufzug aufgebaut
warum haben sie sich das angetan naja
ich meine ich finde er heutzutage
unternehmen so sein gesendet sich was
antun es könnte ja sein dass es mir auch
spaß macht und so ist es bei mir ich
hatte damals für eine große fabrik
die bitte bekommen ihnen zu helfen bei
aldi ins geschäft zu kommen wenn ich mit
aldi 78 wm bücher vertrieben hatte und
dann habe ich dem geholfen
und irgendwann hat er das leberkäs
verkauft und der einkäufer hat
irgendwann gefragt sagen sie mal dr
hudec konvention original nürnberger
rostbratwürste liefern hat gesagt nein
beim einer fabrik ist in standard und
nicht in nürnberg deswegen kann ich
keine original nürnberger liefern
na gut ich würde das nur zu drei wochen
später habe ich mit einem freund den ich
in meinem letzten halbjahr als spieler
in nürnberg kennengelernt hat der hat in
der metzgerei wann er weiß deswegen
kannst die firma auch howe hoeneß und
weiß habe ich ihn gefragt was machst du
denn nun bei eurosport wusste er wie
viel kosten am tag 450 kilo habe ich
sagt 50 kilo
du musst tonnen machen mach mir mal
musste er machte musste ich fix nach
mülheim zu aldi süd der einkäufer sagt
er war hatte ich mich geschmeckt die
zweite dritte muss da hat ihm geschmeckt
sagt ja jetzt habe ich ihr musste haben
sie eine fabrik nein noch nicht
das sind sie verrückt sie wollen uns was
gekauft aber gar keine fabrik dann wenn
sie uns eine chance geben investieren so
gegen es zwei drei wochen hin und her da
wurde ich zum obersten einkauf schwer
von aldi süd gebunden sein forscher
hoeneß was wollen sie uns verkaufen eine
breite von hamburg eine fabrik aber ich
sag geben sie uns die chance der
investieren
das muss ich mir überlegen also aber
sechs weil ich nie vergessen war ich im
trainingslager mit der mannschaft am
tegernsee wir haben abends gegen as rom
gespielt geht mein telefon hier team an
also wir geben ihnen zwei lager einlage
aldi heißt 60 geschäfte für sechs monate
langenselbold und mörfelden bei
frankfurt
wann können sie liefern doch liebe gott
helfen der liebe gott helfen ich habe
gesagt am 15 april
und dann hat man am nächsten tag mein
freund hat er räume gemietet hat uns
seinen metzgermeister zur verfügung
gestellt und einem 14
april habe ich mit meiner frau in
nürnberg die letzten paletten
geschlichtet für die auslieferung am 15
so fing das an heute machen wir bis zu
5.000.000 bratwürste am tag
wir machen wie gesagt ca 50 euro umsatz
und so hat sich das heute aber ganz
moderne verfolgt das ist wie ein high
tech unternehmen
wenn ich immer höre dass heute die
lebensmittel so schlecht sind und dass
sie so unter unhygienischen bedingungen
hergestellt worden
die leute würde ich alle mal in meine
fabrik ein landwirt sind wird gespielt
haben war karl heinz rummenigge und karl
hopfner auf dem weg dorthin hat man noch
zeit haben sie gesagt arthur s
restaurant im moment eine fabrik koste
barschel da habe ich ein paar habe ich
ja da und dann haben wir dort gegessen
da habe ich ihnen kurz die fabrik
gezeigt haben die galaxie konnten sich
das doch gar nicht vorstellen was
heutzutage industriell produzierte was
ist das ist ein high tech unternehmen
da können sie vom fußboden essen und ich
lade jeden ein
unsere wurstfabrik mal anzuschauen und
anschließend wird er vom veganer zum
wurf spezialisten
wir haben nicht mehr so viel zeit man er
lass mich mal alles fragen ich habe mir
kam sogar die fragen sind also sie
begeistert erzählt haben wenn jetzt der
herrgott ihnen sagen würde uli es langt
den rest seines lebens darfst du nur
noch eines machen dich um die wurst um
die fabrik und das familienunternehmen
kümmern oder und oder um den fc bayern
wofür würden sie sich entscheiden dann
würde ich mich um den fc bayern kümmern
weil ich weiß dass die wurstfabrik in
fantastischen händen ist nämlich in
denen meines sohnes florian der einen
superjob macht der ist 33 jahre alt und
er macht das wie der vater nicht mehr so
könnte aber dann gucken wir doch gleich
weiter auf den fc bayern unter ihre
zukunft sie haben nerlinger eigentlich
schon mal so ein bisschen als ihr
nachfolger angedacht gehabt
wieso denken sie eigentlich schon über
nachfolger macht ja weil ich gerade in
der fabrik festgestellt dass man tat
dann aber es ist mit knapp 60 gestorben
ich habe sehr viele freunde aus der
mittelständischen industrie wo es eben
oft nachfolge probleme gibt entweder der
alte lässt zu spät los die jungen sind
zu verwöhnt wollen nur halligalli machen
und nicht arbeiten und für jubeln kann
das geld des vaters und es ist schwierig
oft viele tolle unternehmens sind so vor
die hunde gegangen und das haben wir der
familie in nürnberg wunderbar
hingekriegt und das habe ich auch beim
fc bayern vor weil ich den fc bayern
nicht also eine firma see als einen
company sondern als ein familiäres
problem
jawohl ich will doch nicht ganz
aussteigen ich bin der präsident und
aufsichtsrats-vorsitzender noch fünf
sechs jahre machen
da muss man mal sehen aber die
entscheidenden positionen ist der
vorstand und da ist jetzt karl heinz
rummenigge der 56 das sicherlich noch
fünf jahre machen
karl hopfner scheidet jetzt aus ich bin
ausgeschieden jetzt haben wir matthias
sammer von dem ich total begeistert bin
deren superjob macht und ich denke dass
mit ihm den richtigen in diesem bereich
haben wir haben im marketingbereich
andreas jung geworden in den nächsten
drei vier jahren den operativen bereich
den vorstandsbereich so umgebaut haben
dass wir alten säcke das ist karl heinz
rummenigge dann in fünf jahren und karl
hopfner und ich aus dem aufsichtsrat
schön drüber schauen können wenn wir
über das reden was sie in zukunft machen
weil sie dann schon drüber schauen und
vielleicht ein bisschen beschäftigung
suchen weil so ganz aufhören sagen sie
ja macht keinen sinn könnten sie doch
ein bisschen politik beratungen machen
ich habe mal gelesen ich weiß nicht ob
das wirklich gesagt haben dass sie
gesagt haben sollen
das kann ich mir gut vorstellen so ein
bisschen im hintergrund politikberatung
zumal sie haben gesagt sie war mit
edmund stoiber essen vielleicht gehen
sie auch mit angela merkel essen großer
fan von angela merkel glaube ich bin ich
sehe immer noch obwohl sie gerade den
euro verspielt oder jetzt nicht mehr so
sehr ich bin der meinung dass angela die
größte garantie ist dass der euro
überlebt
total begeistert von ihrer politik und
wenn es mal angela merkel nicht gäbe
zusammen mit unserem finanzminister
schäuble
dann wäre es schlecht bestellt um unser
land denn der euro wird überleben und
das über den erster linie verdienst von
angela merkel und unserem finanzminister
sein weil die eine sensationelle politik
betrieben
sie haben da keine angst vor inflation
und all die dinge die wird unter anderem
in der süddeutschen zeitung als bedenken
wieder der jüngsten ezb entscheidung
lesen kann ich persönlich auch das war
ja eine geniale entscheidung ich bin
überzeugt dass jetzt die weichen
gestellt sind
dass dieses unglaubliche drama was wir
jetzt den letzten 12 monate hatten eine
chance hat bin ich froh dass dies eine
chance hat sich gut zu entwickeln weil
wir jetzt mit dem beschluss der ezb den
hedgefonds den hahn abzudrehen indem sie
sagen wir sind möglicherweise bereit
unendlich zu intervenieren
geben sie denen keine chance mehr und
wir müssen alle begreifen dass die
spekulation in den letzten zehn jahren
die ganze welt kaputt gemacht hat und
nahe dran war
lehmann war der anfang jetzt war das die
fortsetzung wenn es uns nicht gelingt
ruhe reinzubringen und frau mit der ich
immer wieder mal spreche hat mir mal
gesagt wir müssen jetzt fußball spielen
wir müssen auf zeit spielen verlegung
hoffentlich kein elfmeterschießen
und da hat sie total recht und werden
wir uns jetzt die richtige zeit kaufen
wenn wir die richtige maßnahmen
ergreifen und die deutschen und
vielleicht der eine oder andere auf
dieser welt sind gerade dabei das genau
richtige zu tun
dann haben wir alle eine kleine chance
dass es unseren kindern doch wieder
besser gibt das hatte ich vor einem jahr
nicht mehr geglaubt sie sind ja wenn sie
so über hedgefonds und finanzmarkt und
spekulation reden reden sie ja nicht so
der asse sind ja jemand der in diesem
bereich auch tätig ist sie haben ja
machen ja aktiengeschäft oder haben
sagen wir mal wertpapiergeschäfte
gemacht machen sie das noch oder ist in
diese welt unheimlich geworden
ich mache das im kleinen stil hab das
mal
jede kleine bank gemacht in meiner
sturm- und drangzeit ich verstehe was
davon wenn mehr ein bankmanager versucht
zu erklären wie die wiesn termingeschäft
oder all diese dinge laufen musst dann
muss ich manchmal schmunzeln
aber ich muss ehrlich sagen wenn ich da
manchmal so die zeitungen lese dann
denke ich ich verstehe die ganze welt
nicht die haupt problematik ist dass wir
schauen müssen dass wir die welt
wegkriegen von spekulation spekulationen
rohstoffen es kann nicht sein dass ich
einen korn kaufen kann auf reis auch
wenn ich mit diesem kolke geld verdienen
dann geht es den leuten in bangladesch
anschließend schlechter zwangsläufig
obwohl ist völlig egal ist ob die ernte
gut schlecht frost alles kann passieren
aber der manager der lange gegangen ist
der hat sein geld verdient und ob die
leute sterben das interessiert die leute
dicht dasselbe gilt für rohöl das rohöl
im moment ketten wo rauf und runter das
hat nichts mit angebote nachfrage zu tun
sondern weil wie ein paar leute in
irgendwelchen hinterzimmern in chicago
und in und in london entscheiden wo es
langgeht in der hektischen zeit ist
immer donnerstags nachmittag eine
schlechte nachricht gekommen
irgendein einer in nigeria hat ein
pärchen angezündet an einer pipeline und
das zeug wieder drei dollar hochgegangen
ist das gibt es ein zusammenspiel ohne
ende und die ganze welt hat nichts
dagegen gemacht weil die so mächtig sind
die haben so viel kohle zusammen dass
sie die welt beherrscht haben und jetzt
gibt es eine kleine chance eine kleine
chance dass das vielleicht eingedämmt
wird
finanztransaktionen für hundertprozentig
richtig benziner aktie kaufen müssen
finanztransaktionen steuern zahlen des
typs wenn sie die aktie wieder in sechs
monaten verkaufen wenn sie morgens
entscheiden als vor
ich kaufe macht ich gehe ich gebe um
halb neun um zehn nach neun kaufe ich
wieder um viertel nach neun gebe ich
wieder dann mache ich 20 geschäfte am
tag dann soll auch bezahlen
aber er hat eben seine frage nicht
beantwortet aber nicht vielleicht ist so
nah an vielen verantwortlichen in der
politik nicht doch vielleicht
politikberatung machen würde
vielleicht machte schon danke vielleicht
haben sie noch ein satz dazu kommen wir
schon unsere schlussfrage wir haben da
fragen wir fragen immer gerne wir geben
unseren gästen immer gerne drei
alternativen für ihr weiteres leben und
sie können sich eine aussuchen
das würde gespannt also in fünf bis zehn
jahren wie bisher sind mindestens noch
fünf jahre beim fc bayern im
aufsichtsrat
danach werden sie fünf bis zehn kilo
abnehmen vorher gut biergarten am
tegernsee aufmachen würde ich sofort
machen uns selbst bedienen aber ist
jetzt noch nicht der fall kommt dann in
fünf jahren auch selbst bedienen
ich habe nur ein problem ich habe einen
guten freund der hat schon einen unter
dem würde ich ungern konkurrenz machen
können sie gut bedienen perfekt ich bin
ein servicemann ich liebe es andere
leute zu dienen
letzte frage und meinen sie nicht dass
ihr doch mal irgendwann lernen sollten
mit diesem kleinen dingen umzugehen und
zu simsen oder e mails zu schreiben
ich habe mir fest vorgenommen in meinem
leben noch zu lernen einen computer zu
bedienen das ist noch eine aufgabe die
ich noch angehen würde das mal aus sagt
vielleicht noch letzte frage zu ihrem
vierzigsten hochzeitstag haben sie ihre
frau da irgendetwas versprochen was
auswirkungen auf ihren beruf haben
könnte
ja ich hab meiner frau mal zu einem
geburtstag einen gutschein geschenkt
dass wir 14 tage nach coco rheinland
gehen
cocoa island ist eine insel leben im auf
dem aktiven ohne telefon ohne alles und
der gutschein liegt noch da fleck
versuche ich den zu reaktivieren
die 14 tage die müssen sich
rausschneiden vielen vielen herzlichen
dank
uli hoeneß es war großartig ich glaube
ich habe ganz viel mitgenommen
danke ihnen auch fürs zuhören zuschauen
aus dem verlagsgebäude dass die deutsche
seite und forum manager danke und bis
zum nächsten mal